boa noite
o primeiro obrigada pelo pelo convite e
aí eu gostaria de contar pra vocês agora
um pouquinho sobre a minha história de
vida através dos meus intercâmbios com e
zac é de 19 anos quando tive a minha
primeira crise de ansiedade
eu tava é na parada de ônibus esperando
ônibus caí é da faculdade que o trabalho
é um dia bonito tinha solta tudo
tranqüilo e do nada tudo que a gente era
pressa
tinha muita pressa eu tinha muita
vontade de sair dali fazer alguma coisa
porque eu sentia que não estava
aproveitando meu tempo meu tempo ele não
estava sendo é ocupado da melhor maneira
e que ia precisar fazer alguma coisa é
com a minha vida a partir dali eu estava
tendo é mais ou menos o que eu entendia
naquela época como aqueles dos 20 anos
é eu olhava pra frente eu não sabia
exatamente o que acontecer com a gente
nunca sabe e eu olhava para trás e eu
não me orgulhava e nem é sentia que
tinha feito algo relevante é algo muito
importante até o momento é o ônibus
chegou a crise foi passando é eu fui
trabalhar mas a partir dali eu decidi
que precisava fazer alguma coisa e aí
foi quando eu comecei a pensar em
intercâmbio e encontrar comida e zac é
do intercâmbio voluntário é onde eles
falavam que a partir do momento em que
tu é e ajato poderia fazer um trabalho
social em alguma organização e uma ong
uma escola e aprende da lytro
desenvolver a liderança
e aí quando descobrir aquilo foi como se
surgisse uma luz e me dissesse isso eu
vou viajar e conhecer outras culturas
vão conhecer outros lugares e ao mesmo
tempo eu vou colocar o meu o meu tempo
disponível e os meus privilégios a favor
de outras pessoas então é decidir viajar
decidir conhecer o mundo e aí fui parar
na polônia
fui para uma cidade que se chama após
não é num naquela época nem sabia
direito onde ficava a polônia no mapa
mas eu cheguei lá eo meu trabalho era
trabalhar com crianças de 4 a 14 anos
eu estava lá é trabalhando com mais de
200 turmas em escolas
da polônia e e muitas das aulas que eu
dava eram com outros estudantes com
outros voluntários de outros países
estão em uma turma de 25 voluntários de
das mais diversas partes do mundo e aí
por ser com outros voluntários a gente
precisava se juntar a ter um seminário
de preparação quer saber o que cada um
ia falar como é que a gente ia dar as
aulas é sobre cultura sobre eu sou
inglês e tudo mais
é em um dos seminários é a gente estava
falando sobre semiótica estava falando
sobre a identidade imagem de cada país
e aí quando eu tava falando sobre o
brasil é um dos meninos é colocou uma
foto no telão que era de marcar uma
mulher enquanto ela tava é meio do
carnaval era uma foto semi nua porque as
pessoas ficam assim né e bater escolas
de samba durante o carnaval e aí ele
começou aí ele falou assim é assim que a
mulher que todas as mulheres ficam se
veste são no brasil é porque se é assim
eu quero voltar pra falar contigo que
ele prometeu contínuo e aí naquele
momento é eu entendi o que significava é
o problema dos estereótipos
eu entendi o que significava quando
alguém pegava uma imagem e colocava todo
mundo naquela mesma imagem
e aí a única coisa que eu pensei que
precisava levantar e falar e eu levantei
e que acham ele falei é porque está
falando isso com relevante é isso que a
discussão e principalmente porque numa
sala com mais de 25 pessoas é de muitos
países é total exatamente usando
estereótipo para falar sobre alguma
coisa sobre é alguém
e aí é falta de clima meio estranho e
pedi desculpa
o cenário continua acontecendo mas a
melhor parte foi quando é uma das
estudantes que estava lá comigo estava
trabalhando comigo ela era uma estudante
do irã ela veio falar comigo e ela me
agradeceu
ela agradeceu por eu ter levantado e
falado porque naquele momento não
entendeu que ela também era responsável
por levantar e falar quando alguém
falava sobre os estereótipos do país
dela e principalmente sobre estereótipos
da mulher do país dela é o projeto
seguiu por mais dois meses
o projeto onde é eu consegui trabalhar
muito com as crianças e também consegui
me apaixonar muito pela polônia
conseguir é conhecer muitas pessoas e
foi uma experiência que é marcou com
certeza minha vida mas ela só metade da
experiência porque depois é eu viajei de
volta ao brasil fiquei menos de 24 horas
aqui em porto alegre e um dia depois eu
estava voando pra argentina no segundo
projeto voluntário é fica em uma cidade
chamada mendonça uma cidade que fica
quase na fronteira com o chile e lá eu
trabalhava é uma ong para moradores de
rua então é trabalhava lá com outros
estudantes com outros intercambistas ea
nossa idéia era trabalhar com a
comunicação daquela ong porque a gente
queria fazer um evento de final de ano
que iria fazer uma uma ceia de natal
onde as pessoas que moravam na rua elas
pudessem ter um momento pra é ter
alimentação tempo é roupas pra ganhar
durante aquela sei quando escolhi a
argentina quando eu decidir e príncipe
país eu pensava que o meu choque
cultural ele seria muito pequeno porque
a argentina é muito próximo aqui de
porto alegre a cultura é muito parecida
à alimentação é muito parecida e
realmente quando cheguei lá o choque
cultural ele foi muito pequeno mas eu
tive um choque social eu era uma
estudante de classe média é sustentada
pelos pais que tinha é privilégio
bastante pra cantar a faculdade e viajar
durante um semestre para conhecer vários
lugares do mundo enquanto estava
trabalhando com moradores de rua é que
tinha uma pouca noção da cidade deles
que dirá do país e precisavam me
relacionar com eles a ponto de os dois
se sentirem os dois lados se sentirem
confortáveis com aquilo então eu
trabalhava na ong
eu resolvi aumentar uma carga de
trabalho digamos assim eu trabalhava na
ong é das 9 da anda manhã às oito da
noite
durante a manhã cuidava do projeto
ensina da comunicação daquele evento e
tudo mais mas durante a tarde eu
colocava é colocado à disposição
daqueles moradores de rua para poder
auxiliar de suporte que eles precisavam
é às vezes só conversar com eles e poder
está presente porque para eles é não
fazer nenhum sentido uma pessoa do
brasil tá ali disponível para conversar
com eles era é era algo que não passava
pela cabeça deles pela realidade que
eles viviam
e foi numa dessas conversas é que eu
estava andando falando com eles falando
sobre como tava tavam tava todas as
coisas e aí eu tava com ruan eo cargos e
à necessidade que eram 33 dos moradores
de rua e aí é eles me perguntaram como
estava a minha experiência que está
deixando a cidade e eu falei que eu mais
gostava era de mendonça das pessoas
nesse momento luan que é um deles
ele começou a rir é deus em uma risada e
falou assim é thomas pessoas como assim
é porque tem os mendocinos e tem os
mendocinos os mendocinos eles vem sempre
em primeiro lugar e demorei ainda nem
estava falando
só que mais tarde baixou a cabeça dela e
aí quando entende de novo a única coisa
que eu pensei foi preciso falar é ele de
novo o questionei falei que não não
entendia não concordar com quem estava
falando e ainda os meninos da ong mesmo
os voluntários da ong ele interrompeu a
conversa chamou o que é sair para
conversar é ou era um homem de 50 e 60
anos
e aí eu não podia falar pra ele que
estava pensando não podia questionar ele
precisava falar com ela porque ela se
sentiu mal e evidente lado e falei não
concordo com o que ele falou pra mim é
indiferente e pra mim não faz sentido é
a gente usa o gênero que é diferenciar
os direitos ou a voz de uma pessoa
e aí pra minha surpresa ela me olhou e
olhar dela tinha alívio e a mercedes é
uma mulher que tinha cinco filhos ela
tinha perdido o marido e ela morava na
rua com três filhas peso daquela cinco
filhas
e aí é naquele momento ela olhou pra mim
sorriu é e falou é muito obrigada por
ter falado isso porque eu sempre falei
isso para os meus filhos e é muito bom
saber que tem mais pessoas que defendem
se essa mesma
essa mesma visão é e acreditam nisso
também
o projeto também foi muito bom foi
projeto que a gente conseguiu ter uma
ceia de natal para mais de 400 moradores
de rua e aí eu voltei pro porto alegre
e aí quando eu voltei depois de quase
seis meses de viagem àquela 15 dos 20
anos ela não existia mais
é ainda existia pressa mas a peça tinha
dado lugar pra outros dois sentimentos é
quando tive que quando olhava pra trás
pra mim é a minha experiência e eu via
que eu tive que falar sobre estereótipos
e eu tive que falar sobre direito e voz
eu tive que ter muita coragem eu tive
que levantar e defender algo que eu
acreditava enquanto enxergava algo que
me incomodava em duas partes do mundo
que não é fácil que eu estava acostumada
a thaicom as pessoas que estava como
está acostumado a conviver
quando tive que falar com uma jovem é
como um estudante do irã e quando eu
tive que falar com uma mulher é da
argentina morador de rua e tive que tem
empatia que eu precisava entender qual é
o local de fala delas sobre o que ela
estava falando e principalmente que ela
sentiu enquanto falavam sobre aquilo e
óbvio é a minha a minha viagem ela foi
incrível aprendi muita coisa sobre o
mundo mas principalmente entende que uma
moeda muito grande e que ele tinha muita
coisa pra mim pra mim ensinar é eu fui
eu fui pra fora eu olhei para fora eu
olhei pra muita coisa mas isso só me
ajudou poder olhar para dentro e
entender o que era meu e que não ia
mudar independente do lugar da etapa
eu podia tá na polônia e um pediatra na
argentina e pediu está falando como
moradores de rua ou uma estudante queda
do irã mas tinha coisas que eu não ia
aceitar que fossem errados e mais do que
isso eu precisava usar minha voz para
falar sobre isso
é aquela coisa dos 20 ela não existia
mais muito porque eu tinha entendido é o
que fazer e como é como usar os meus
privilégios e tudo mais para levar isso
para outras pessoas e foi aí que entendi
o que era aquela liderança que é que
falava que desenvolvi porque hoje pra
mim a liderança é muito mais
é o momento em que tu entende a tua
causa e tusa tua causa pra falar por
aquilo mas principalmente
faz algo que é tão verdadeiro então
forte petit que acaba inspirando
encorajando as pessoas a seguirem a tua
causa ou a própria causa delas também
nisso muito obrigado
[Aplausos]